Louis ridic who does a great job with
the NFL joining us on the program Louis
good morning how are you I'm doing great
dad how are you thanks for having me on
sure let me start with at the top I
don't know I'm sure you saw where Pete
Prisco of CBS sports.com had a headline
that said you know maybe the Cardinals
are gonna pass on Cuyler Murray question
mark why would that be out why would
that information be out there today on
Monday
well there's a lot of information
quarter unquote that's out there on
Monday that isn't necessarily incredible
information or good information because
you know I think GM right now is this
play guys by they like to play I'm going
to trick you I'm gonna put some feelers
out there just to kind of keep people
you know guessing as to what exactly it
is that they're going to do because then
it doesn't really benefit them to have
anybody know exactly what they want to
do and I'm sure so look if you look at
it objectively there's a number of
different reasons as to why not grab a
quarterback would make sense for them
also as far as building out the rest of
the football team and besides the fact
that you know what just a little while
ago about a year ago they did great
trade up to draft the kid named Josh
Rosen grabbed through the be there you
know who happens on a play of just one
season behind an abysmal offensive line
it's a lot of potentially gonna go ahead
and sit down the road for another
quarterback so okay there's a number of
ups or I'm sure that in that
organization in that drew those grass in
their exact they're meeting right now
and at the highest levels of that
organization they're sitting there going
are we really gonna do this are we
really going to a year removed from
drafting what we thought was our
franchise quarterback gonna grab another
one well I guess it's possible
considering the date you know a little
coach out of there in less than a year
as well so close up now know what they
know what they're doing so I can't
really tell about what they're gonna do
at the top of the draft this year I mean
it's a weird it's a very unique
situation with them all right what would
you do and what should the Cardinals do
if you were the GM and you had the final
choice what would you do at the top of
the draft
well I'll tell you this look if I if I
hired Kliff Kingsbury and my owner was
sitting there at the press conference
will to introduce him saying did you
watch him a Texas Tech do you remember
how that office was there I want some of
that here in the valley I want an office
type our political offense like that
that's what's exciting to me that's why
the way it's going that'll put people in
the seats that's what these people
excited well then I'm going well okay
well how are we going to get the book
what really gives us the best chance to
bring all those things that he's really
just described to this football team
well our coach has already said how much
he loves calibre that is he would grab
the number one overall pretty good in
the job well I think you know that's it
that's what we want and we're really
resetting this organization once again
and the coach feels very strongly that
this guy gives us the best chance to
bring all those things that the only
want him dressing calamari that's what
I'm doing now objectively speaking if we
hadn't encode cuz we were just looking
at this football team organically and
trying to just build it yeah you can
look what you could look at making the
case for drafting one of these defensive
linemen in particular and concluding the
builder's football team front to back
and make sure we take care of office the
feeders of line and you'd be looking at
both so there's you look at quited
Williams that's the other kind of guys
you looking at because those are the
kind of guys that make sense to go on to
in terms of trying to build this
football team
you know objectively but it's not like
that if he's only way to my college we
talked about at the top of exactly
because the unique circumstances
surrounding this coach what he said we
kind of following the breadcrumbs as far
as what Michael goodwill said at their
opening press conference and why they
hired Kliff Kingsbury in the first place
so it's what we would do objectively and
what this team is probably going to do
and a lot and the ones along with what
they're thinking they don't match up and
that's what makes it so intriguing
that's why you're gonna have people
saying maybe they don't Jack I'll
there's people saying run my percentage
Jeff Carly we don't know that's why you
gotta tune in hope not second best
quarterback in the draft or second
quarterback to be drafted if that's one
in the same yeah and they're not the
best quarterback in this chat is 20 past
second quarter has to be dread maybe
drew Locke maybe Dan Jones I don't know
we're going that is going to go I don't
know how I think all teams had these
guys that there's differently because
quarterback is about flavor it's about
style okay wait Louis Louis let me go
back in this so you're saying the best
quarterback in this draft is just
learning to happen his weight Haskins no
doubt there's no doubt about it
he is and I know his resume is limited
one year as a starter what did the kind
of coaching that he got at Ohio State
Ryan basically in the NFL people could
be knocking down his door to try and get
him to the NFL why because his passing
game concepts even explode in 2019
honestly has been reached their
potential as far as what they can do all
offensively man that's a whole nother
story
Dwayne highly highly football
intelligent just listen to the guy
explain Ohio State's passing concepts
listen and explain how these guys has
tried to play them and why he made the
decisions that he made you why Luke if
you touch them as far as throwing the
football
classic pocket passer who has underrated
this diagnose mobility in the pocket the
guy who can spread the ball horizontally
vertically controlled at all three
levels Hudson Columbus weapons at Ohio
State there's really nothing not to like
about him nothing he grew every game
this past year I know he only has one
years it's going on but within that one
year you saw him faced adversity within
games from week to week and always
figured out always come out on top when
I went to his pro day look and I'm one
of the people who has said don't get in
amber with pro days this it's just a
piece of the puzzle that's another piece
of information to use I'm telling you he
worked on everything that he needed to
work on between the kind of season ended
in that probate the kind of you know
calm people's fear that one he didn't
have quick feet or didn't have mobility
in the pocket which is ridiculous he
does and two that he couldn't go on the
run with consistent accuracy which if
you watched his pro day the kid has a
clip done disarmed and tremendous acted
like there's nothing I collect there's
not if you put him in a situation where
ideally
Duane could sit for a year really get
comfortable with the offense continue to
work on his physical maturation
and learn and watch how some of the best
professors can play that position
prepare play the game correct mistakes
after the game is over prepare the next
week take care of their body to cure
themselves off the field it's a guy who
actually touchdown this year his second
year in the pros who had the benefit of
sitting and learning from the same type
of guy in Kansas City that being Patrick
the home run and come out of it Wayne
can get that situation I could see the
same kind of thing happening to him
provided that they put the weapons
around him like an deport around Patrick
I can see the same type of thing
happening you know it's ironic I don't
think going past 15 to Washington anyway
although he may never play again we
don't know Alex Smith guess who else is
in Washington case team it's a perfect
situation to learn now they have a lot
of work to do as far as you can weapon
but I'm telling you can see I could go
on and on about him he is a fantastic
fantastic prospect who I've gotten to
know personally pretty well now I just
as this Creek that process is going on
I'm Allman I'm all little number seven
for my estate the best player in the
draft is oh wow you know III would say
this this is a Texan people by surprise
the best player in the stuff some people
take when Williams and Cleveland say
look throw so I painted this for my
money pound for pound the best player
and the strength is definition inside
linebacker if you can tell me exactly
what his weaknesses that weakness is I
can sort of play that so tells you it's
not a weakness I played with his father
in Atlanta in 1996 or 97 95 one of those
years anyway his father was a saint from
Claude is good this kid has all of his
father's canonically speed striking
ability he has better performance than
his football smarts are off the charts
but is that an important position no
Louis that that would be my question
you know what the great
the game is changed and I mean game as
far as how people are attacking you on
offense has it's become critical to have
great athletes smart athletes in the
middle of the field at linebacker and
safety that's why you see guys like
Rokon smith drafted as high as you got
directed by Chicago last year that's why
Devon White's going to go top ten this
year now issue that's why Devon Bush is
going to go top ten from from Michigan
this year you better be able to defend
teams that can attack you with running
backs tight ends in the middle of the
field where you're not allowed to hit
anybody or some great athletes who teams
will just carve you up between the
numbers right down the field first down
first down how knowing what has this
kind of like made the rest of the league
look silly they started doing it years
ago with Gronk and Hernandez they still
do it now now they just changed their
philosophy a little bit as Gronk got
over and they started doing what it was
running backs Lex Burke had James White
the guys who you're catching passes over
and over again you're going I was crazy
doing this bill has always been out
ahead of the curve you better start
catching up as far as getting athletes
in the middle mathilde you don't lie
back and safety they're not throwing
with positions anymore they're just not
if you don't have them you won't stop
anybody in the NFL maybe that's what the
league wants that's how things kind of
if you hit if you do it that way as a
team builder they're not going to stop
anyone that's why you're gonna see more
and more guys who can play defense like
that combat something these hybrid
Titans who better have it's the same
thing like I why the Clinton Nelson go
as high as he did to infinity Annapolis
last year well more teams are looking
for Fletcher Cox and Aaron Donald why
because all the best core let's says
give me a defensive tackle if I have a
defensive tackle that's going to just
absolutely just terrorize me right up
the gut play after play like Aaron and
Fletcher that type the best rattled me
and get me off of them a day well the
only way uses the bat collector cars and
Aaron Donnell because he decides if you
have eyes like Quentin Nelson the game
change man it's not just about well I
just got to have a quarter and a left
tackle and a pass rusher after that I'm
good that you can find me any old office
just to play guards it's not like that
anymore
and that's why positional does
change with Mork and if you're not with
that just not you that's not going to be
claiming guys or even ultimately with
Ted nori and the best teams are doing it
and that team of the wing ones been
doing it years now yeah I add a scout
who told me last year that Nelson he
thought was the best player in the draft
and that's why when the Colts took him I
said you know what they got a guy that
gonna be there ten years he's gonna be
an all-pro and he's he plays with an
attitude and he you know he's he's ready
for the challenge and he lived up to the
hype as well we're talking to Louis
Riddick from ESPN I'll leave you with
this Louis the potential top 15 pick who
makes you nervous oh boy I would
probably say the one that makes me
nervous the most is Montez from
Mississippi State and not necessarily
because what what and obviously because
you know there's some there's some
concern about you know his health from a
heart condition standpoint that's you
know that information is out there you
know but um you know our teams that will
take them off the board there are teams
that won't be concerned about it that
it's a suit that it's a deal that he can
play with and teams are not that
concerned in another team saying look we
won't want to assume the risk going past
that though despite the fact that he is
a absolute freak in a phenomenon from an
athletic standpoint is call on as long
as it's fast you know one in row four
fourth as big into unity that is
ridiculous they're not supposed to do
that I think one of those guys didn't
watch this film is no doesn't always
look like his combine worked out to us
and those guys always scare me yeah talk
about somebody who can go maybe in the
top ten and who may have a health
concern that's a tricky one for me
that's one of those guys that keep an
eye on remember his name on Thursday
night because I'm sure you'll if his
name starts sliding Saturn will start to
increase about is it the health concern
in at the concern that maybe his clay
doesn't match up with his measurables so
he's the one that was scared to the most
in it
great stuff Lewis have fun in Nashville
tell the boys we set a low and we
appreciate your time as always
absolutely that's a Lewis Riddick
ESPN NFL analyst I think he likes to
Wayne Haskins just a little bit there
that's a little bit of a warm take there
for Lois Riddick ESPN's coverage live
from Nashville all seven rounds Thursday
night Trey Wingo milk Piper and booger
mcFarland on the ESPN main set ESPN to
the main sent Friday night and Saturday
they have their coverage throughout the
weekend as well for more Dan Patrick
show tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV streamed for free on BR Live or
download the Dan Patrick show app